The
next excerpt is taken from original tape two eighty six side
one were in the boat.
But again the
birth is something there are some taboos
that
cause no way that we
still do follow the native
way could be a little
distracting motionless
to hear us through the
medicine
and
know
that traditionally
India lifestyle pertaining to
lifestyle
is the simple philosophies. Never
to get so
excited when you can
approach the same
person sees something that it should
be and I
think all people in the way of
understanding things in your
environment
is that their
sole purpose for everything
the reasons
they're especially human
relations and I think the
early
pregnancy that the father of
both parents mother
to be has to be
cautious
be able to do it in the.
Forest
and driving down the
road and
of course the
cripple or kill running over
the
rabbit that if I can take care of
my wife
to
eventually
cause me to
miscarry the child will be
born
tingle
because of these accidents
previous
times he could
help but it takes a simple develop a child
development straight for every function.
Normally like for instance
manner. When we used to come
to medicine
man. The reason to cause he was
mentally but just to double check in no way should
enough a medicine man easily identify
the need but you should.
Killing any entity
of that nature and with that when the mice.
Choose purify.
Do cause you perfectly right.
And then you probably take care of the
procedure.
But do it right the structures that the medicine
man gave me and
psychologically didn't
develop he could like the infant he's been
checked extremely thoroughly and
care in any hospital but yet they could say.
Please do this
but
sometimes but of course you have
to have safe
haven. So with the faith as a base.
You just do that entirely up to that
point and
eventually get a natural development.
And it's your school by starting to your
natural born.
So a lot of times he takes these things in an anglo
way of looking at things. Brenda
that a lot of times you see these things.
It has been for the
husband.
But again if it is so that
the parent
like deer hunting season.
If your wife is expecting you should call.
You're liable to damage the board. Do
you he was going through the
proper
ritual wonders go
by way
but it may
cause some
difficulty to be a normal person. So you have to wait.
Charlies mentally physically. Then you have
to wait to do you need to
feel with
a soul the soul the
cautioning structures the
parents paternalist most
terminals to
the company. Right.
Respective people that we. Listen
because everybody was
normal
baby. And lot
of times. Again another thing that there's death in
the family with the media
family who are born expect.
Well if you see a dead body being dead body.
You have to
see. Other than the dead bodies being
brought up into
grief and if you haven't been in an
area just a little Glenn's psychological
effect with the
Charlies born.
They normally are schemes just
like
any person to
identify it you know kind of
pale in this
cause that.
Normally we
have me twice in the United States
or specialize in a certain way to take your
newborn
in and they could visited one of the
ancient archaeological
site
close to yours and they also do find
a human to bring it
back and I don't really know
exactly the steps that they take your newborn.
But these
these claims here for cation.
And that erases the pill and that that
the newborn child. It's natural
color so good that
this terminates I think or little staff members of
the nation are kind of dealing with medicine.
Well we have good relations
that Israel has
done
medicine lodges for eternity.
Just
a couple things here. This is just pertaining to new book.
And
I
think more and more
medical
experimentation causes. Physically
and mentally. Indian people understand
that even necessary to
have a medical. Which medical term.
I have experienced.
And tried to do the
experimentation
with this he
was approached
the medicine
man
in the hospital but he
was. Really call into
that for more
examination but a couple of days.
Back. Knowing
that drugged me because I guess my wife was
expecting one
to
rent a doll. Going to
work accidentally that we should
have to. Loyalty.
But sometimes it slipped your mind.
We had to carry property before it was born. I'm pretty sure we could
but
again it's pretty hard to tell it's hard to write.
Well
to
be straightforward with you so I think the
greatest confrontation we are
facing
legal
drug supply the trade union
drugs illegal and sites and
I
guess hard hard
drugs as well as of course you're
in the zone a reservation. You can still prohibit it. Even though
the
building has green just like the nation.
We haven't adopted that it's been said by
previous council that we had as well this community see if we could help
the liquor establishment.
There will be that many
major accidents in the highways but
again.
I personally see this as a great is number
one
element within the Zune and I guess if you look at
Nationwide one of the.
Only.
So really I think that really. But if you as
an indian been done. Be under the
dominant
society with that in
your system I guess you're allowed to do.
That much
quicker than didn't realize you
only because I personally experienced.
Number one system.
The illness in my
life. No one else India and Indian had surrounded
with respect. Specially
Selamat my philosophy on my paternal side.
My grandfather was the
student he brought me to love and you were lost in
the mother age of five. My grandfather was.
My mother my
father
and he saw me through the
difficult world
war and
peace condemnation and judgement.
So I was accustomed to
that and a lot of times as a
young. Selfish mind personally.
But he put me with this
understanding what he expected me to
expect teaching my
basic principles of law pertaining to morals.
Behavior attitude discipline. You know whatever it
takes to train your mind for the early
development. So I went away.
This is my personal
view that after I complete.
My schoolbag the fifty's. I was
told that I went to St Joseph's
College used to be university develop a creek.
Universe developer could get a couple of
semesters scholarships. Took some of the academic
courses but was getting decent. But my
subjects every.
Completed my two semesters at the greeting card with
me during Korean War So I was
drafted mentally so wordy
my system I
know that I was going to get my
grandfather but it
must when you read or forced to defend your country.
For democracy. You know that I have to follow that
order two years of that was
pretty nigh tried to escape from
reality.
But I didn't call but all except to the
bottle benches or leaker. But a time
when I went back to
my
drinking took me several years to
come and once again. Or I came
from ready had a
little stunned.
Why. It took me
to the point to
play personally inventory.
Little by little I recognize my
weakness. And somehow I think
also with my mind and my right to my
surroundings the disputes of my ancestors.
I know that several times like you were praying to many patients.
My mother left me
read and finally when I came
to my turning
point it was that sobriety.
Folks it's been like twenty eight years since I touched this.
So really I think a lot of times in life
recognize these major one number one thing.
That almost killed me. I have to hit the bottom
to learn that I have to make an alternative
way to eat or to feed the grave was started to pick up
the gilded
bag. My dear friends I think this is
something that I
played the smartest thing.
I think
this also effects the sequel
says. Lee
were you know mental physically you
both will be trading your own drug
dealings with a given person has to recognise weaknesses.
Although I do have and I'm not a
psychologist or haven't taken any courses in psychology
but I believe in my store poisons.
I use my strong points to bring my
weaknesses and I think.
Two courses since a college that is is a great.
Way as
well enough to
fix scientific findings.
So really life is seen just like a lot of times.
What we had learned the hard line hard she shared with
others like oh my
God I do they
will make myself clear with the world.
What I had
before I think
there's much thing that in life that we.
Sometimes we take it for
granted we don't seem to recognize this.
Ability.
Woodworking capable of doing
it and I think these is what helps me to
understand life that much.
So I also do
it with young people that have lost a
beloved I helped to wipe off the years.
What
would sooner or later make a man of themselves.
Like I
did so I will come
to the point it was suicidal.
So many young people today working the purpose. There still exist.
Especially the place like
hereis and bring.
The arrangements with teachers.
Help them
through. Life
is. A unique being will make one
especially a Native American Indian.
Life is too short a precious thing. I don't
know
I analyzed a lot of these things to make my
theory because I think I have a pretty good imaginative idea
a creative life style to develop a lot of these ideas.
To understand
life because a list of you
still face the mobs sudden death.
But before much more a word to say slight. Whatever.
However like scum prochoice every minute
and. That the guy also
help others takes
a can that always be a need
but it's all a sweetie facing cold. No
understanding the cause of the.
Later in life when I look at my I will be free to do these companies.
So I think the more you would surely live.
Use your
native son a different way to
figure so doing is like ours is just a calculated
move with the
the spirals spiral
really picked to
please a certain shortest day of the year the
longest to see a thing or ancestors were scientific
minded folk and kids today.
I
am I was bored traditional
board tournament. Either.
One of the religious offices for eternity.
For
eternity. My grandfather
of course was a High Priest.
So all the explanation and the structures that I received
bold help me to understand.
It was in service I know what the world is it's a competitive
world and the one thing that the
world lacks I think you know ways cordial to
share with these people.
Was a lot of big cities especially when it was guided missile
training other times people move in and out
so they don't seem to really get
this
basic you know cultural need life that
we supposed to know and I think this also
gives back to the
way at this time an age
that overpopulated population and Sunni school would
take less or less or some of
these basic teachings before God specially when young
people move away from their birthplace.
Step or in the subdivision areas.
And not enough basic traditional teachings exist.
So I think during court or in this program with the school district
provide new services to or students. Of course
to little or to stick figures. Illustrate build
up this visual aid.
Think
be aware if they're pretty artistic people
ascribe scoreless coasters they can come with their case
because Native American people
stick to their craft
and magination
are so much a similar base
that
Indians and this is the way
I work with young and
old I don't know maybe he says can too
much. In a sense.
Just to but everybody today can take here
locally produced. That's their
strong
point
it's nothing but pride and dignity from
within and so many times I
think especially the economy and
jewelry black several years
ago. And this is throughout the nation I guess
the crafts of young
people and a lot of times
or angle of friends that are here as traders do in the jewelry business.
They don't seem to respect the feeling that in the end in a
way like if you present a crass to one individual
by discreetly look at it and shove
it was I have more of these come back next time you
know stop right
there and then if this individual try another person with the
same
attitude. It's one.
And if you've
tried this much to other
cars but he's working speed put it
hurts he said city.
We've
seen him take your
bill or could be a provider for you
know one of
them.
I think Indian It's only
slight I've trained my mind
to
train other
young
to give up a life.
Don't give up your talent to produce whatever you can with
your IT.